the texas shooting is all too familiar
to most of us so is the reaction on
capitol hill where as we know the
argument over new gun laws is split
along party lines senate democrats say
they'll try to force action this week
they have the backing of president biden
who denounced gun sellers and their
supporters in a white house statement
last night scott mcfarland has more from
capitol hill
president biden who was midair and route
back from a trip to asia when the
shooting spree unfolded spoke to the
nation tuesday night shortly after his
arrival back at the white house as a
nation we have to ask when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby so far it hasn't happened in the
last decade since the sandy hook
shooting congress largely democrats has
tried and failed to pass nearly 20 gun
control measures
the school shooting in uvalde
immediately stirred senators to speak
and familiar divisions emerged this body
has been complicit
by its inaction
in fact
it isn't this body
it is
members of this body principally on
the other side of the aisle we know from
past experience that the most effective
tool for keeping kids safe
is armed law enforcement on the campus
the fbi just released an alarming report
showing a spike in the number of active
shooter incidents last year 61 of them
almost double the number from 2017 and a
significant increase from just the prior
year while a separate report from an
advocacy group found 77 shooting
incidents on school grounds just this
year and 14 deaths a number that more
than doubled yesterday we have to
act and don't tell me
we can't have an impact on this carnage
fbi director christopher wray testifies
here later today about the uvalde
investigation and the agency's overall
response to gun violence also here today
the nominee to lead the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms steve
dettelbach that agency hasn't had a
confirmed leader in seven years
michelle another thing congress
can't agree on
startling scott thank you